raúl qué tal estoy aquí en el norte de
francia los altos de francia esta región
y concretamente en el departamento del
para de cale este es un feudo de la
extrema derecha aquí dentro de dos horas
tendrá lugar uno de los dos actos entre
las dos vueltas de marina volumen y por
qué eligió esta ciudad porque bueno en
general yo decía este es un feudo de la
extrema derecha en la región y obtuvo un
33 36 por ciento de los votos de la
primera vuelta un 38 68 en el
departamento del para de cale donde
ellas diputadas sin embargo en la ciudad
de arras siempre le ha sido esquiva aquí
ganó el presidente manuel macro con un
29 48 por ciento de los votos de ella se
citó en un segundo lugar con 24 puntos
61 y hubo 20 por ciento de los votos
para el melón son por eso ella está aquí
para conquistar justamente al electorado
de izquierda ya los indecisos recordemos
que es una ciudad con una fuerte
desindustrialización en los años 80 por
lo tanto hay mucha gente que quedó sin
trabajo después de eso que trabajaba en
el carbón ese es el blanco que ella
tiene aquí les va a hablar obviamente
del poder adquisitivo que es un tema
fuerte y del poder adquisitivo también
le hablo hablo perdón a raúl a unos
camioneros en la ruta en el camino hacia
aquí hacia el norte concretamente en roa
esto es en la sombra y ahí analizó el
debate que tuvo frente al presidente
manuel macro anoche ya dijo to be free
to be frente a mí mismo a un emanuel
macrón fiel a sí mismo arrogante dijo y
que menosprecia a las personas incluso
su postura fue arrogante dijo ella